if we talk about subjective well-being
there are two really different ways of
looking at it and one is to look at
people's mood or state of mind they live
their life and the other is to measure
their satisfaction or their emotional
reaction when they think about their
life we know now that these two are
really quite different and they they're
sensitive to different factors so the
thing that make you satisfied - not
necessarily make you happy
people have very little idea you know
how their tastes will change they're
susceptible first of all to what we call
a focusing illusion and that is makes it
virtually impossible to think straight
about your own life nothing is quite as
important as you think it is while
you're thinking about it so the mere act
of thinking about something makes it
more important that it's going to be so
you're thinking how much happier would I
be living in California and you know you
think oh you'd be a lot happier well no
you won't be a lot happier how much
happier would I be you know if my income
increased by 30% you think a lot no you
know it wouldn't so just about
everything that people think about they
exaggerate its importance if you look at
life satisfaction at what makes people
satisfied with their lives
you know most of what we know it has a
lot to do with people's goals when we
ask people how important money is to
them when they're 18 and we look at
their income at age 45 we find that the
people who said at age 18 that money
didn't matter to them very much at 8:45
money doesn't matter to them very much
so there the correlation between their
income and their satisfaction with life
is really very low the people said that
money is very important to them those
who made a lot of money are really quite
satisfied with their lives and those who
didn't make a lot of
really quite miserable so goals are very
important to life satisfaction